[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من نرى الله والتوتر
المتصاعد في الضفه الغربيه خصوصا بعد قرار
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تعزيز قوته في
الضفه الغربيه بكتيبه رابعه بدء من مسائل
اليوم
وهذه الصور تريدنا مباشره من لندن حيث
توصلت الحكومه البريطانيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي الى اتفاق ينهي خلافهما بشان
مراقبه مرحله ما بعد او الخروج من الاتحاد
الاوروبي في ايرلندا الشماليه
وتاتينا هذه الصور من مقر الامم المتحده
في نيويورك حيث اطلق مبعوث الامم المتحده
الى ليبيا مبادره جديده لاجراء انتخابات
تشريعيه ورئاسيه خلال العام الجاري
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
تصعيد ما بعد تفهمات العقبه جيش الاحتلال
يحاصر اريحا بعد مقتل مستوطن في اطلاق نار
ويفرض طوقا امنيا على حواره وقرى جنوبي
نابلس وينشر كتيبه اضافيه في الضفه لتامين
المستوطنات والخارجات الامريكيه تدين عنف
المستوطنين العشوائي والواسع ضد المدنيين
الفلسطينيين
الازمه تتصاعد في تونس جبهه الخلاص
المعارضه تدعو للتظاهر للمطالبه بالافراج
عن المعتقلين السياسيين من جميع التيارات
وحزب التيار الشعبي المؤيد لمسار الرئيس
سعيد يدعو السلطات لتوضيح حقيقه
الاعتقالات الاخيره
مع احتدام المعارك في باخموت شرقيه
اوكرانيا
روسيا تقول ان المبادره الصينيه للسلام
يجب ان تراعي مصالح الاطراف كافه
يحذر الغرب تعرض روسيا للخطر سيعني ان
مصير العالم لن يتقرر في اوكرانيا وانما
خارج حدودها
من جديد مضيق تايوان في الواجهه بعد اعلان
وزاره دفاع تحليق طائره عسكريه امريكيه
فوق المضيق بيجين تندد وتعتبر الخطوه
تهديدا لامن واستقرار المضيق وسفير واشنطن
لديها يقول ان حفاظ بلاده على القوه
العسكريه في تايوان ومحيطها ياتي لضمان
ردع اي هجمات صينيه على الجزيره
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تصاعد التوتر في الضفه
الغربيه بعد يوم من تفاهمات والتزامات
اجتماع العقبه وفرض جيش الاحتلال طوقا
امنيا على حواره وقرى جنوبي نابلس استطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم الى اين تتجه
الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه بعد اجتماع
العقبه
78% قالوا ان الاوضاع متجهه لمزيد من
التصعيد فيما صوت 7% لصالح هدوء الاوضاع
بينما راى 15% ان الوضع سيرابح مكانه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد فرضيه امريكيه تفيد بان فيروس كورونا
تسرب اثراء حادث عرضي في مختبر صيني بيجين
ترفض بشده وتتهم واشنطن بتشويه سمعتها
وفي الحصاد ايضا الجزيره في ملف خاص ترصد
التنافس في شرق اسيا واسباب التوتر بين
واشنطن
اذا قال جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بيان
مسلحين داخل سياره اطلق النيران على سياره
اسرائيليه عند مفترق للطرق جنوب البحر
الميت في منطقه الاغوار ما ادى الى مقتل
اسرائيلي اضاف البيان انه مواصلوا تحرك
نحو اريحا واطلقوا النار واستهدفوا سياره
ثانيه بينما كانوا يغادرون المكان وقال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه اشتبك معهم اثناء
حرقهم لسياراتهم لكنهم فروا من المكان
بيان الجيش اضاف ان الجيش والشرطه يقومان
بعمليه تمشيط واسعه النطاق بحثا عنهم وقد
تم نشر الحواجز العسكريه وتشديد عمليات
التفتيش حول اريحا وقالت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه ان العمليه تاتي في اطار الرد
على جرائم الاحتلال ومستوطنيه
وقد اعلن جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تعزيز
قواته في منطقه نابلس شماليه الضفه
الغربيه بكتابه عسكريه رابعه منذ بدء
تعزيز قوته في المنطقه الليله الماضيه
ياتي قرار جيش الاحتلال عقب مشاورات
اجراها وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يواف مع
قياده الجيش خلال جوله تفقديه في موقع
عمليه حواره التي اسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنين
اثنين وقد حملت السلطه الفلسطينيه حكومه
نتنياهو مسؤوليه هجمات المستوطنين في
حواره
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البوديري زارت بلده
حواره في نابلس بالضفه الغربيه ورصدت اثار
الاعتداءات وما خلفه احراق مستوطنين عددا
من المنازل
قبل قليل راينا موكب لوزير القومي
الاسرائيلي
يمر هنا من الشارع الرئيسي في بلده حواره
تحت حراسه الامنيه اسرائيليه مشدده بالطبع
المنطقه مغلقه بالكامل لا اي فلسطيني يسمح
له بالدخول او الخروج اذا كل ما داخل حوار
تقريبا مغلقه هذه البلده التي توصل نابلس
بجنوب ووسط الضفه الغربيه نحن هنا امام
احد المنازل التي تم احراقها من قبل
المستوطنين ليله امس كما نرى المشهد يتحدث
عن نفسه حرق كامل للمنزل الدخان لا زلزال
يتصاعد من ما اكده لنا الاهالي انه في
داخل هذا البيت كان على الاقل هناك خمس
نساء وعدد من الاطفال اضطروا للهرب فور
رؤيه المستوطنين يدخلون الى عمق المنطقه
الحقيقه هنا وهو داخل احد الاصدقاء
القريبه من الشارع الرئيس الترولي الهرب
وصل عدد من الشبان
حاولوا التصدي
للمستوطنين الذين اكد الاهالي ان عددهم
كان يزيد عن 200 هذا واحد من اكثر من 30
منزلا تم حرقه من قبل المستوطنين الذين
دخلوا الى البلده من كافه الاجهاد تحت
حمايه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
معنا من رام الله مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو
شماله سمير مرحبا بك كيف يتطور الموقف في
اريحا وايضا في نابلس ومحيطها حيث
التعزيزات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
نعم في البدايه هناك بعض المعلومات قد
ذكرتها واعلنت عنها وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه بان القتيل الاسرائيليه الذي
قتل في الهجوم قرب البحر الميت الميت هو
يحمل الجنسيه الامريكيه حيث اعلن عن مقتله
متاثرا بجروحه اصيب بها في عدد الهجوم
المسلح الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل ايضا قد
اعلن في بيادن حول التحقيقات الاوليه
بخصوص هذا الحادث بان هناك كان اطلاق رصاص
من مجموعه من المسلحين على احدى المركبات
ولكن المركبه الثانيه ثلاث نقاط كان هناك
هجمات على هذه المركبات في مواقع مختلفه
وكان هناك اطلاق نار على هذه المركبه ما
اصابها سائق المركبه بالرصاص في الجزء
العلوي من جسده ومن ثم واصلت المجموعه
المسلحه الى قرب مفترق مستوطنه الموج
واطلقت النار على سياره اخرى كانت تقل
زوجين من الضيوف لديهما ولم تصاب هذه
العائله وهؤلاء الافراد في هذه السياره
باي اصابات ولكن الرصاص قد اصاب جسم
المركبه وقد توجه المسلحون الى المنطقه
القريبه من مدينه اريحا حسب ما نشر جيش
الاحتلال في بيانه وكذب قد تم احراق
المركبه التي كان
يستخدمانها في عمليه هذا اليوم قرب مدينه
اريحا الجيش الاحتلال نشر
الحواجز العسكريه واغلق واطبق الخناق على
الفلسطينيين في مداخل ومخارج مدينه اريحا
وايضا كان هناك اغلاق او وقف لعمليه
المغادره للركاب والمواطنين المسافرين الى
الاردن وذلك في اجراء احترازي امني من قبل
جيش الاسرائيليه على صعيد مدينه نابلس كان
هناك بعض
الصدمات المحدوده بين بعض المستوطنين
والفلسطينيين في بلده حوار تحديدا وايضا
كان هناك تجمعات
لمستوطنين عند بعض المطابخ القريبه من
المستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه وايضا وقعت
بعض الصدمات مما ادى الى اصابه اثنين من
الفلسطينيين وايضا اصابه احد المستوطنين
يعرف يعرف انه كان ضابط في جيش الاحتلال
قد اصيب بجروح جراء رشقه بالحجاره قرب او
شمال مدينه رام الله هذا هو ما يجري حتى
هذه اللحظه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
شكرا لك
عرب المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه نيد برايس عن قلق الاداره
الامريكيه الشديد ازاء العنف الذي وقع في
بدايه الاسبوع في اسرائيل والضفت الغربيه
وقال ان الهجمات التي ادت الى مقتل
فلسطيني واصابه اكثر من 300 اخرين بجروح
خطيره واحراق منازل وسيارات فلسطينيه هي
اعمال غير مقبوله على الاطلاق اضاف برايس
انه يتوقع من الحكومه الاسرائيليه ضمان
المساءله الكامله للمسؤولين عن الهجمات
على الفلسطينيين وتقديم تعويضات عن
المنازل والممتلكات المفقوده واكد ان
واشنطن تريد ان ترى الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين ينفذون الالتزامات التي
اقروها في بيان اجتماع العقبه في الاردن
واشار الى ان الاسرائيليين وافقوا على عدم
ترخيص اي بؤره استيطانيه جديده لمده سته
اشهر على الاقل وتتوقع واشنطن منهم الوفاء
بالتزاماتهم
معنى من واشنطن مراسله الجزيره بسان ابو
كويك بيسان ماذا في تفاصيل هذا الموقف
هذا طبعا موقف لافت من وزاره المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه
تحديدا مع الاحداث المتواليه في الضفه
الغربيه طبعا الخارجيه الامريكيه والبيت
الابيض ايضا قبل قليل ادانا العنف بكافه
اشكاله ولكن
تحدث تحديدا على الهجمات التي طالت
الفلسطينيين من قبل مستوطنين بادانه ذلك
ووصفه بانه غير مقبول ومطالبه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
باتخاذ موقف حازم بمسائله المسؤولين عن
الهجمات التي استهدفت
الفلسطينيين ومنازلهم وحتى وصلت حد القتل
على حد قولهم على حد قوله عفوا بالمحاكمه
وتعويض الفلسطينيين عن هذه الخسائر التي
طالتهم طبعا سمعنا منه ايضا مطالبه
الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
بالالتزام
ببيان وما خرج عنه اجتماع العقبه
والتزام اسرائيل ايضا في قضيه البؤر
الاستيطانيه وعدم المضي قدما في ذلك ايضا
البيت الابيض والمتحدث باسم البيت الابيض
اكدت على ضروره طريق الوحيد الذي تراه هذه
الاداره الاداره الامريكيه وهو حل
الدولتين وان
الاستمرار في عمليات الاستيطان يمثل عقبه
امام هذا الحل وطبعا
اعادت ايضا تكرار ما قاله بيان الرئيس
الاسرائيلي بانه يجب ان لا ياخذ كما قال
المواطنون يعني القضيه او العنف بايديهم
ان يمارسوهم السلطه بايديهم هذا ما جاء
على لسان متحدث باسم البيت الابيض ولكن
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ناد
برايس شدد على ادانته على الهجمات التي
نفذها مستوطنون على فلسطينيين ومنازلهم
وضروره تعويض الفلسطينيين ومحاسبه
المسؤولين شكرا لك
بيسان ابو كويك مراسلتنا في واشنطن
من القدس معنى الي نيسان الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي الاسرائيلي لماذا شاركت اسرائيل
في اجتماع العقبه اذا كانت تنوي الانقلاب
على نتائج فورا
اولا كما تعلمين ان كانت هناك خمسه توجهات
في الحكومه السابقه برئاسه بنت وبراسه
ولكن الحكومه
برئاستهما
خشت من ان تقوم بمشاركه بمثل هذه القمه
ولكن بسبب انتقادات من قبل نتنياهو واليوم
عندما
نتنياهو يتراس سده الحكم في اسرائيل هو
وافق نزولا لمطالبه الولايات المتحده بهذا
الموضوع الكل كان كان له
نيه بان مع حلول شهر رمضان المبارك
اذا كانت مصر والاردن والولايات المتحده
وحتى الجانب الفلسطيني
الذي في البدايه وافق على المشاركه في هذه
القمه ثم بعد ما حدث في نابلس تقريبا
تراجعه
نعم المسؤولون الاسرائيليون يذهبون الى
قمه العقبه يوافقون على بيان يصدر الى
اجتماع العقبه يوافقون على بيان يصدر يقول
بان اسرائيل تلتزم بوقف الاستيطان لمده
سته اشهر بعدم اتخاذ اي اجراءات احاديه
الجانب وخفض التصعيد
وقبل ان يعودوا الى اسرائيل يحصل ما حصل
في حواره وتخرج التصريحات التصريحات من
قبل رئيس الحكومه بالقول انه لن يجري
الالتزام بذلك لماذا انا متاسف على نص هذا
السؤال هذا السؤال عندما كان اعضاء اللجنه
او القمه
[تصفيق]
يناقشون امكانيه
مواصله الهدوء
تمهيدا لشهر رمضان المبارك وقع حادث مقتل
الاخوين في حواره وتم بعد مقتل الاخوين في
حواره حدث ما حدث في حواره انا اقول انا
اقول بصراحه
بعد صدور البيان وبعد ان قال اسمعني
اسمعني قال نتنياهو انه لن يلتزم بوقف
الاستيطان
لا لا لا كان هناك اولا اتفاق بانه يتم
بناخ
9500 منزل في الضفه الغربيه
اعتراض بتسعه
مستوطنات عشوائيه
ستكون شرعيه هذا هو كان الاتفاق مع حتى
بمعرفه الولايات المتحده ولكن الخارجيه
الامريكيه تقول اليوم في لحظه لحظه تقول
الخارجيه الامريكيه اليوم في تصريح رسمي
ان الاسرائيليين وافقوا على عدم ترخيص اي
بؤره استطانيه جديده لمده سته اشهر على
الاقل وتتوقع منهم الوفاء بالتزاماتهم
بس انا اريد ان اصحح كلامك كلامك بان هناك
هذا كلام الخارجي لا اذا اذا انت تريد فقط
تسالين انا انا هذه انا متاسف لا تعطيني
موافقه كانت هناك انا اصحح كلامك لانك
كانت هناك موافقه على بناء
منزل في الضفه الغربيه في المستوطنات
والاعتراف بتسعه مستوطنات عشوائيه ولكن
بعد مطالبه الولايات المتحده وبعد ان وافق
كل الاطراف اذا مصر والاردن والجانب
الفلسطيني والولايات المتحده واسرائيل على
المشاركه في القمه وافقت اسرائيل نزولا
الى مطالبه الولايات المتحده بان اسرائيل
تجمد بناء بناء اي منزل في المستوطنات وت
ايضا بناء مستوطنات جديده لمده سته اشهر
وهذا هو مع وافقت عليه اسرائيل ولكن ولكن
انا اريد ان اقول ان هذا هو التزام
اسرائيل هناك مطالبه من قبل المستوطنين
بعد ان راينا مقتل الاخوين واليوم راينا
مقتل في في منطقه اريحا اعتقد ان هناك
اولاء انا اعتقد وان هناك مطالبه من قبل
المستوى العسكري في اسرائيل بان على
نتنياهو ان يتخذ اجراءات صارمه ضد الارهاب
في المناطق لانه منذ شهر هناك تم قتل اكثر
من 14 مواطنا بريء وليس مسلح من بين من
بينهم لحظات من بينهم سبعه او ثمانيه
مصلين الذين خرجوا من مصلى
السياسي الاسرائيلي من القدس
من رام الله ينضم الينا منير الجاغوب
القيادي في حركه فتح ومعنا من غزه حسن
لافي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي سيد منير
الجاغوب ما تقييمكم في حركه فتح لما حدث
لما وصلت اليه الامور بعد اجتماع العقبه
لا هي قبل اجتماع العقبه وبعد اجتماع
العقبه الامور واضحه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وجيشه يطلق عنان
المستوطنين ويحميهم خلال هجومهم على
الفلسطينيين في حواره وفي بيتا وفي عين
ابوس وفي جماعين وفي كل المناطق المحيطه
في حواره يعني هذا لم يتوقف يوما الاجرام
الاسرائيلي والارهاب الاسرائيلي كان
الاحتلال اذا كان ذلك معلوما لديكم سيد
منير لماذا
توجهت السلطه الفلسطينيه الى المشاركه في
اجتماع العقبه ما الجد وكان من ذلك السلطه
السلطه الفلسطينيه ذهبت بناء على رغبه من
الاشقاء العرب ومن الولايات المتحده لشرح
وجهه النظر الفلسطينيه ووضعوا النقاط
الفلسطينيه على الطاوله وهي 13 نقطه كانت
واضحه المعالم ولا لبسه فيها ابدا لها
علاقه في الاستيطان لها علاقه باقتحام
مجلس الا لها علاقه وهذا هو كان الاطول في
اسرانا الابطال في سجون الاحتلال وما
يتعرضون له وكان هناك تعهدات عربيه
وامريكيه
بتنفيذ هذه الشروط وخرج البيان النهائي
الذي كان به ما شاهدتموه وما تحدثت به قبل
قليل
لضيفك
المحتل الاسرائيلي اسرائيل اسرائيل دائما
تتنكر لهذا الموضوع ولكن ايضا السلطه
الفلسطينيه سوف تذهب الى اخر الدنيا لشرح
ما يحدث على الارض الفلسطينيه بالتالي هذا
لا نقيس فيه ان تذهبي وتتحدثي بهموم شعبك
ومشاكله تحديدا ان هناك اطراف عربيه
موجوده على هذه الطاوله وهي تقيم ايضا
علاقات مع اسرائيل وممكن ان تكون مؤثره في
رفع الظلم والقتل والاجرام اليومي عن
الشعب الفلسطيني في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع
غزه والقدس والشتات لم يكن هناك اذا سيد
حسن لافي من خساره للذهاب والمشاركه في
هذا الاجتماع بما ان الان يظهر ان من
ينقلب على هذه التفاهمات هو الطرف
الاسرائيلي
انا اعتقد ان هذا الكلام يعني غير صحيح
بالمطلق هناك خساره كبيره للسلطه
الفلسطينيه اولا ومن ثم للشعب الفلسطيني
السلطه الفلسطينيه منذ عام 2014 وهي تضع
شروطا سياسيه لاي لقاء سياسي يجمع يجمعها
مع الاسرائيلي له علاقه بصفقه قلنا نتذكر
صفقه كيري عام 2014
ودفعه الاخيره التي تنكر لها
الاسرائيلي بشكل كبير ونحن الان امام
اداره امريكيه
ديمقراطيه كان رئيسها نائب للرئيس
الامريكي السابق اوباما لم لم تطلب لم
تطلب السلطه حتى الافراج عن هؤلاء الاسرى
التي يعني يجب ان يكون هناك واجبا يعني
اخلاقيا تجاه تجاههم من قبل الامريكان
الامر الثاني هناك حاله يعني مشتعله في
الضفه الغربيه لماذا الاهتمام الامريكي
بشهر رمضان لماذا الاهتمام العربي في شهر
رمضان لان هناك خطر على على اسرائيل وعلى
امن اسرائيل وبالتالي كان ل السلطه اوراق
ممكن ان تستخدمها للضغط حقيقه اذا كانت
يعني لديها الرغبه ولديها الاراده حقيقه
ان تذهب الى الى الى الى قمه العقبه لكن
ذهبت الى قمه العقل بلا اشياء بدون اي
اثمان الامر الاخير في هذا الاطار البيان
الذي يتكلم به الاستاذ الجاوب اي بيان
عندما يكون في هذا البيان تجريم للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه والحاله الشعبيه في الضفه
الغربيه واطلاق عليها مسمى الفوضى والشغب
ويكون هناك خطه لمواجهه هذا الامر تحت
عنوان كبير جدا اسرائيل للاسف الشديد
ترفضه وهو فرض الامنيه للسلطه الفلسطينيه
على الضفه الغربيه من الذي
يهدد الفلسطينيه الاجتماع هل هو هو هل هي
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ام المستوطنين ام
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه والجيش
الجاغوب كيف ترد على هذه النقاط خصوصا
فيما يتعلق بان هذا الاجتماع هذا الاجتماع
كان مخصصا لمواجهه المخاطر ضد اسرائيل
وليس مواجهه يعني او او
اعطاء ما يصوب في مصلحه الطرف الفلسطيني
يعني للاسف الشديد دائما هذا الحديث يصدر
عن الفصائل الفلسطينيه بدون تمعن اذا كان
هذا الموضوع حقيقه ام غير حقيقي من ذهب
ليفاض اسرائيل اشخاص معروفين ومن ذهب الى
قمه العقبه ايضا اشخاص معروفين جزء منهم
كان اسرى في سجون الاحتلال وجزء الاحتلال
قتل والده واستشهد بتال لم يذهب اشخاص
ليجلسوا على الطاوله مشكوك في وطنيتهم هذا
هو ثاني شيء دائما يتم تصوير اي لقاء تقوم
به السلطه الفلسطينيه او القياده
الفلسطينيه بانه لها علاقه بالتنازل ولو
علاقه بالخضوع له علاقه بالنكوس وله علاقه
بالتنازل عن الثوابت الفلسطينيه ما هي
الثوابت التي تنازلت عنها السلطه
الفلسطينيه ثانيا نحن لم نذهب الى اجتماع
امني يعني حسين الشيخ ليس جنرالا في
السلطه الفلسطينيه هو رجل سياسي وان ذهب
معه الاخ ماجد فرج ذهب لموضوع له علاقه
ايضا في اللجنه لها علاقه في تسليم باقي
الاراضي للسلطه الف لسطينيه واعاده سيطره
السلطه الفلسطينيه وليس لتجريم المقاومه
وليس لتجريب المقاومه وحبس المقاومين
انقلبت اسرائيل على كل ما التزمت به في
البيان بيان اجتماع العقبه ما الخطوات
التاليه في هذا المسار خصوصا وان السيد
حسين الشيخ يتحدث عن المشاركه في اجتماع
مقبل في شرم الشيخ في السابع من اذار
المقبل
يا سيدتي حركه فتح يعني ترفع
كارما وشعار كبير لا ممكن ان تتنازل عنه
ابدا
ما دام الاحتلال موجود المواجهه مفتوحه
هذا وهذا ما تؤمن به حركه فتح الان نذهب
نفاوض نقاتل على الارض مثل امس من كان في
الميدان معروف وكل قنواتكم نقلت من كان في
ميدان المعركه
وعملت مقابلات من الميدان مع كوادر حركه
فتح وامناء سر حركه فتح ومن قاد المواجهات
امس في الدفاع عن بلده حواره والقوى
المجاوره ايضا كوادر حركه فتح بالتالي
حركه فتح يعني هناك اتجاه سياسي
للقياده الفلسطينيه وهناك اتجاه مقاوم
ومواجه على الارض تقوم بدورها به حركه فتح
بالتالي
يعني الطرفين او القسمين يكملان بعضهما
البعض لا يوجد انفصال ما بين هذا وما بين
هذاك بالتالي يعني لماذا نركز على العقبه
ولا نركز ماذا قامت حركه فتح في الضفه
الغربيه يوم امس ماذا فعلت كتائب شهداء
الاقصى يوم امس من منطقه
المستوطنين يوم لماذا فقط التركيز على
لقاء العقبه
للاسف الشديد يعني السلطه دوما يعني تحاول
يعني خلط الاوراق وتميع الامور
يعني هناك فرصه حقيقيه وهناك هامش حقيقي
للسلطه الفلسطينيه سواء على المستوى
الدبلوماسي او حتى على مستوى اداره الملف
الداخلي الفلسطينيه ان تستفيد من القناع
الكامله للمجتمع الدولي ان هناك حكومه
ارهابيه في اسرائيل لا احد يعني لن يبدو
الجهدا كثير السيد حسين الشيخ ان يقنع
الامريكان حتى انه
ارهابيين ولذلك مطلوب منه ان يستخدم هذه
الورقه ولا ولا يساوم عليها بالمناسبه يجب
ان يكون لدينا اراده لتفعيل هذه القضيه
بشكل كبير الامر الثاني سيذهب في السابع
من الشهر المقبل لشرم الشيخ ماذا نتج عن
عن العقبه يعني ماذا نتج عن قمه العقبه
وماذا استفاد الشعب الفلسطيني منها ولا
وحتى في البيان الذي انا اعتبره انه يمص
بالاخلاقيات الوطنيه للشعب الفلسطيني
عندما يمس بجوهر المقاومه حتى هذا
الاستيطان مستمر القتل ممنهج وهذه الخديعه
الكبرى التي يقول ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يعني
خجل جدا مما فعله المستوطنون المستوطنون
هم الا من الات الاحتلال كما هو الجيش
الاسرائيلي تخيل ان هناك شاب فلسطيني دخل
على على اي مستوطنه سيقف الجيش الاسرائيلي
يتفرج هناك اشكاليه كبرى لدى السلطه
بفهمها لاداره الملف الفلسطيني حقيقه لابد
ان تكون امام خيار واضح وهو خيار الشاب
خيار المواجهه مع الاحتلال في كافه الاطر
ولكن لا يمكن لاحد ان يسمح لها ان تستثمر
او تحاول ان تجعل من هذا الحاله الانتفاضه
الشعبيه في الضفه الغربيه حلل الاستثمار
للمصالح الشخصيه لبعض الافراد في السلطه
الفلسطينيه
السياسي وشكرا لضيفنا من رام الله منير
الجاغوب القيادي في حركه فتح شكرا لكمما
[موسيقى]
الى تونس حيث قال رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني
احمد نجيب الشابي ان الحمله القمعيه
الحاليه ضد المعارضين ليست سوى تجل من
تجليات تخبط السلطه وفي مؤتمر صحفي اعلن
ان الجبهه ستنظم تظاهره في العاصمه الاحد
القادم للمطالبه باطلاق سراح جميع
المعتقلين
الشيء هذا احنا كنا متوقعين قبل
الانتخابات
واعلنا عنه منذ شهر او جوان الماضي لان
هذا الحكم الفردي المطلق ما ينجم يبسط
نفوذه الا باسكات صوت المعارضين وصوت كل
نفس حر في هذا البلد قلنا بان القيادات
الحركه السياسيه
والمدنيه الاجتماعيه النقابيه مستهدفه
ايضا
معنى من تونس مدير مكتب الجزيره لطفي حاجي
لطفي ماذا في اخر المواقف وردود الفعل
السياسيه على ما يحصل
والتحضيرات لهذه التظاهره التي اعلن عنها
نعمل ردود الفعل من الجانب المعارضه سواء
كانت جبهه الخلاص او غيرها من الاحزاب
المعارضه تعتبر ان هذه الاعتقالات هي
اعتقالات سياسيه بامتياز كما كما تقول ولا
علاقه لها بما يروج من ناحيه التامل على
امن الدوله او الانتماء الى تنظيم ارهابي
كما ورد في العناوين الكبرى ودليل على ذلك
ان ما قام به المعتقلون من افعاله هي تدخل
في باب العمل السياسي حيث يحاكموا الجميع
على اجتماعا عقدوه مع تركي بغايه البحث عن
حلول للمازق الاقتصادي والسياسي الذي
تتردى فيه البلاد كما يقولون وانه من حق
المعارضه ان تتجمع في جبهات او في كتل من
اجل انجاز هذا
الهدف او هذه الوصول الى هذه الافاقه في
دوله تعتمد على مشروعيه الاحزاب
[موسيقى]
هو سجين هو مورط في مسار التامل واعلاميه
معروفه واخذ بهذه
الوشايه وكانها امر مؤكد بالنسبه اليهم
ولذلك هم من ناحيه القضائيه القانونيه
ينسفون كل ما تروجه السلطه وكل ما تروجه
بعض الصفحات المواليه للسلطه ويؤكدونها
ويشدون على انها محاكمه سياسيه نعم شكرا
لك مدير مكتب الجزيره في تونس لطفي حجه
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا حيث ما زالت المعارك تحتدم
في ضخمه تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها
تستهدف عناصر ميليشيا فاجنر خارج حدود
المدينه فيما ترد بان شيء يوقفها وانها في
الطرق نحو او في الطريق نحو احكام القبضه
عليها حديث ميدانيه تزامن مع عقوبات جديده
من الغرب للتضييق على موسكو فرضتها
الولايات المتحده وكندا التعليق الروسي
كان بالاشاره الى استعدادات للرد على هذه
العقوبات سجلات الميدان والسياسه تتزامن
هذه المره مع نافذه دبلوماسيه نافذه
فتحتها الصين المتهمه بشروع في مساعده
روسيا وتقول بيجين ان مبادرتها تسعى
لانهاء الازمه ترحب كييف بالامر وتقول
موسكو ان الوقت غير مناسب
يحتدم القتال ميدانيا مدينه بخموت لا تزال
مسرحا لقتال عنيف القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول
الابقاء عليها
ذراع موسكو الاقوى هناك تقول انها تقترب
من الامساك بها
وتعلو اصوات تلوح بهاجمات وشيكه موعدها
الربيع لا شيء في مشريات الميدان في
اوكرانيا يشير الى وقف قريب للمعارك
والتخندق وراء الحليف سواء كان موسكو او
كييف مستمر الغرب يعد بمزيد من الاسلحه
لكييف وشرق يقترب من موسكو خطوه اضافيه
رغم هذا تعلن الصين انها ستقدم مبادره
للتسويه وتنشر ما تقول انه موقفها من
التسويه السياسيه للازمه الاوكرانيه
يرد موقف بيتجين في اثنتي عشره نقطه اهمها
احترام سياده الدول التخلي عن عقليه الحرب
البارده وقف الاعمال العدائيه استئناف
الحوار المباشر الحفاظ على امن المنشات
النوويه وعدم التلويح باستخدام السلاح
النووي ووقف العمل بالعقوبات احاديه
الجانب التي لم يقرها مجلس الامن اضافه
لبنود تضمن سلامه المدنيين وممرات الغذاء
وسلاسل الامداد واعاده الاعمار المبادره
الصينيه لم تاتي دون سياق بشكل كامل سبق
انسحاب روسيا من معاهده ستارت وزياره لوفد
صيني رفيع الى موسكو السياق هذا ان تجاى
ردود فعل متباينه موسكو رحبت بدايه وقال
الكريم انه يولي اهتماما بخطه السلام التي
طرحها الاصدقاء الصينيون الا ان تفاصيلها
يجب ان تخضع لتحليل دقيق وحسابات وهي
عمليه طويله ومرهقه
رحبت ببعض عناصر الاقتراح الصيني لكن
الرئيس الاوكراني وصف المبادره الصينيه
بانها بعض الافكار التي لا توافق بلاده
عليها جميعها الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسي يانس
ان الصين لا تتمتع بمصداقيه كبيره اما
الموقف الاكثر صرامه فصدر من واشنطن
الرئيس الامريكي قال انه لم يرى شيئا
مفيدا في الطرح الصيني لاي احد غير روسيا
وفيما لا يبدو ان الاجواء مهيئه للسياسه
يشتد التوتر بين المعسكرين في اكثر من
ساحه ليست اوكرانيا الا واحده منها
قال زعيم دونيتسك الموالي لروسيا ان
الظروف في جبهه باخموت مؤتيه لتطويق من
سماه العدو وتضييق الحصار عليه اما مستشار
فقال ان ميليشيا فاجنر تخوض معارك في مركز
مدينه
طرق المؤديه اليها اصبحت تحت السيطره
الناريه للقوات الروسيه
معنا من كييف كيرا رودك العضو في البرلمان
الاوكراني ورئيسه حزب هولوس سيده كيرا
ما دلالات الموقف الروسي الذي يبدو اليوم
غير متحمسا كثيرا لخطه السلام الصينيه كيف
تقراه كييف
البدايه يجب ان نتحدث عن اهميه التوقيت
توقيت خطه السلام الصينيه حيث ان هذه
الخطه اعلن عنها بعد عام على هذا الاجتياح
نحن نعرف ان الصين تحاول ان تؤدي دورا في
عمليه السلام ولكن في الوقت نفسه هناك
نقاشات بالنسبه الى تزويد روسيا بالاسلحه
ولذلك هذا لا يعطينا اي سبب لكي نثق بان
هذه الخطه سوف تطبق لذلك روسيا لا تاخذ
هذه الخطه على محمل الجد ولهذا السبب ما
من ثقه اساسيه بهذه الخطه على انها الخطه
التي يمكن ان تؤدي الى نتائج يمكننا ان
نتحدث عن النقطه الاولى النقطه الاولى هي
احترام سياده البلاد وحدود البلا د اذا ما
بدانا بالنقطه الاولى يبرز التساؤل لماذا
توافق روسيا على هذه النقطه توافق روسيا
على هذه النقطه لانه بالنسبه الى روسيا
الاراضي التي ضمت بشكل يخرق القوانين
الدوليه هي اراد روسيه هذا غير مقبول من
قبل اوكرانيا
ولكن المعادله التي كتبت فيها هذه النقطه
السيده
ولكن نقاط كلها وردت في الخطه وربما قد
تكون خاضعه للنقاش او للتفاوض لان الصين
لم تقل انها يعني خطه يجب ان تؤخذ كما هي
لكن السؤال هو ان هذه الخطه اليوم
توفر نافذه دبلوماسيه للطرفين
الا يجب التمسك بها في هذه المرحله
النقطه المهمه هي ان روسيا اعتدت على دوله
ذات السياده وهي اوكرانيا وارتكبت كل
انواع جرائم الحرب في اوكرانيا وبالتالي
الا في حال عرفنا ان القوات الروسيه سوف
تنسحب من الاراضي الاوكرانيه وكل من ارتكب
الجرائم سوف يحاكم ما من مفاوضات
دبلوماسيه نحن نتحدث عن نقطتين في خطتنا
نحن للسلام كل شخص اتى لقتلنا واغتصاب
نسائنا سوف يعاقب والقوات الروسيه يجب ان
تخرج من اوكرانيا هذه هي النقطه الرئيسه
بالنسبه الينا وكل النقاط الاخرى يتم
التناقش بها
ولكنها غير اساسيه ما من
شكرا لك وضحت الفكره العضو في البرلمان
الاوكراني ورئيسه حزب هولوس ضيفتنا من
كييف
من موسكو معنا السفير اندريه باكلانوف
نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس سيد
السفير اندريه باك لانوف كيف يمكن ان نفسر
هذا الموقف الروسي من الخطه الصينيه بدايه
كان الموقف مرحبا اليوم يبدو متريثا يتم
الحديث عن ان اللحظه للسلام لماذا
بكل صراحه بكل صراحه
بين اراد ديفيكا والسيتي نحن في وضع صعب
لاننا
نقوم
بالترحيب
بانخراطي الصين كقوه عظمى في هذه
المحاولات الاله الى حل الازمه
وبعض النقاط الوارده في تلك الخطه هي
اساسيه على سبيل المثال سلامه
المحطات النوويه باضافه الى امور اخرى
ولكن لسوء الحظ هناك امور اضافيه المشكله
ليست بالخطه بحد ذاتها بل المشكله مرتبطه
بالوضع الذي نواجهه وعلى الاقل يمكننا ان
نتحدث عن نقطتين لا تتسمان بالواقعيه في
هذه الخطه النقطه الاولى هي العوده الى
طاوله المفاوضات نحن نرى ان هذا التوقع
غير واقعي
لان اوكرانيا قالت وبكل صراحه وبشكل لا
لبس فيه انها لن تتناقش بمساله
ابدا بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا هذه المشكله
مفتوته وبالنسبه الى روسيا تقول روسيا ان
هذه المساله
انتهت
المناطق الاربعه عادت الى روسيا وبالتالي
من الصعوبه بمكان ان يتفاوض الطرفان بشان
هذه المساله
عطفا على هذا الموقف الذي تتخذه روسيا من
الخطه السينيه سيد اندريه بك لانوف يخرج
ديمتري ميدفيديز ليهدد بان
مصير العالم لن يتقرر في اوكرانيا وانما
خارج حدودها ما معنى هذا الكلام
يسهل تسهل عمليات شرح هذا الامر اذا
اوكرانيا او دعونا نقول السلطه في كييف
السلطه في كييف التي وصلت بعد انقلابا غير
قانوني في العام
2014 لا يمكنها ان تبقى وتستمر من دون
مساعده مباشره من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والدول الاوروبيه ودول حلف شمال
الاطلسي في الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن معركه
بين الاتحاد الروسي
ومن جهه اخرى الدول المنضويه تحت لواء حلف
شمال الاطلسي والتي تزود اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه على انواعها وترسل المرتزقه
بالالاف الى اوكرانيا وبالتالي ليست
المعركه بين روسيا واوكرانيا بل هي معركه
بين روسيا والدول الغربيه شكرا لك السفير
اندريه نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين
الروس ضيفنا من موسكو
[موسيقى]
في حضور صيني امريكي اخر نقلت وكاله
رويترز عن وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه قولها
ان طائرات عسكريه امريكيه حلقت فوق مضيق
تايوان وقالت الوكاله ان طائره الامريكيه
وهي من طراز بي 8 اي بوسيدن عبرت المضيق
من الشمال الى الجنوب دون اعطاء مزيدا من
التفاصيل
الجيش الصيني قال انه راقب الطائره
الامريكيه عن كسب وهي تحلق فوق المضيق
اضاف ان الامر يهدد الامن والاستقرار في
المضيق وشددت المؤسسه العسكريه الصينيه
على رفضها هذا العمل الامريكي
التنافس الامريكي الصيني يعكس الصراعا حول
نفوذ والزعامه العالميين حيث تصفه الاوساط
السياسيه الامريكيه بانه اكبر تحد
جيوستراتيجي للولايات المتحده في القرن 21
الجزيره وفي سلسله تقارير خاصه بملف
التوتر في شرق اسيا تسلط الضوء في اول
تقاريرها على اسباب التوتر بين اكبر قوتين
في العالم
رغم الود الظاهري خلال اخر لقاء بين
الرئيسين الامريكي والصيني الا ان التنافس
الدولي الذي يزداد حده بين اكبر قوتين
دوليتين يجعل العالم يقف برمته على اعتاب
حرب بارده في نسختها الثانيه
[موسيقى]
حسب تقييمات البانتاجون فان الجيش الصيني
يعمل على تنويع منصات الصواريخ النوويه
لمواكبه توسع ترسانته كما انه اجرى
اختبارات لصواريخ البالسيه عام 2021 كانت
اكثر من بقيه دول العالم مجتمعه ويطور
صواريخ تفوق سرعه الصوت اما في مجال
الفضاء فتشتبه واشنطن ان بيوجين تعمل على
تطوير اقمار اصطناعيه للمراقبه وجمع
المعلومات وتسعى في الوقت نفسه لانشاء
قواعد عسكريه لها في انحاء العالم ينظر
ذلك بصراع هيمنه على مسارات تعتبرها
الولايات المتحده شريانا حيويا للملاحه
والتجاره الدوليه يكثر الحديث هنا عن
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادي
اتتهم الصين بانشاء مناطق خالصه لها في
بحر جنوب الصين بانشائها جزرا صناعيه رغم
رفض جيرانها لما بمزاعم السياده الصينيه
وهي منطقه تلعب دورا حيويا في تدفق النفط
والتجاره لحلفاء واشنطن في شرق اسيا
كاليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وتايوان في
الاقتصاد ورغم كون الصين ثالث اكبر شريك
للولايات المتحده فان اتهامات واشنطن
لبيجين تواصلت بشان ممارسات اقتصاديه قالت
انها تنتهك قواعد منظمه التجاره العالميه
كنقل التكنولوجيا وسرقه الملكيه الفكريه
والاسرار التجاريه مخاوف واشنطن زادت بعد
اطلاق بيجين مبادره الحزام والطريق عام
2013 حيث تتوجس من ان هذه المبادره التي
وقعتها 146 دوله حتى الان ستعزز توسع
الصين العسكري وسطوتها الاقتصاديه في
العالم
ولا يقل تنافس في مجال التكنولوجيا في
اهميته عن باقي ابعاد هذا الصراع اذ اتخذت
الولايات المتحده اجراءات حظر على شركات
الرقائق الالكترونيه لبيع الشرائح
المتقدمه للصين والتي قد تستخدم في المجال
العسكري لا سيما التجسس كل هذه التحديات
وغيرها دفعت واشنطن لاطلاق سياسه ما يوصف
بالردع الموسع تهدف من خلالها الى تشكيل
ما يعرف بالبيئه الاستراتيجيه حول بيجين
من خلال الاستثمار في القدرات التكنولوجيه
والعسكريه وتعبئه حلفائها وتنشيط سلاسل
التوليد العالميه بعيدا عن التبعيه
الصينيه
وتبقى تايوان الفتيله الذي قد يفجر الموقف
في ايه لحظه فالجزيره التي تعتبرها الصين
جزءا منها تحظى بمظله عسكريه امريكيه ما
قد يفتح الباب على مواجهه متعدده الابعاد
في المنطقه
هنا ايضا تبقى تايوان ضمن اهم الخطوط
الحمراء التي تسعى الصين لمنع الولايات
المتحده من تجاوزها ولذا تسعى بشكل حثيث
لامتلاك قوه عسكريه نوعيه
تؤمن لها تفوقا في البحار من شرق الصين
حتى جنوبها هذا السعيد تجلى واضحا في
مناورات الصين البحريه وطلعتها الجويه شبه
اليوميه بالقرب من تايوان بل تجاوز ذلك
لتجري بيجين تدريبات عسكريه في مناطق غرب
المحيط الهادئ وتقترب حامله طائراتها
لعونين من جزيره غوام اكبر قاعده عسكريه
امريكيه في المحيط
امام التغيرات الحاده بالوضع الدولي وخاصه
في وجه تصرفات الابتزاز والاحتواء والحصار
والضغط الشديد من الخارج
تمسكنا بمصالح الدوله
مصالح تمثلت في خطط اقتصاديه وصناعيه
طموحه وضعت الصين لتحقيقها سقفا زمنيا
محددا
في عام 2015 اعلنت الصين عن خطه صنع في
الصين
لتحقيق التفوق في مجال الصناعات عاليه
التقنيه وبعدها بعامين اعلنت عن خطتها
لتحقيق الرياده في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي
بحلول عام 2030
لطالما وصفت الصين منع الولايات المتحده
الرقائق الالكترونيه
واشباه الموصلات عن كبريات شركاتها
التكنولوجيه بالقمع والاحتواء واعتبرته
وقوفا في طريق تطورها التقني الذي استثمرت
فيه مليارات الدولارات
تنفي الصين لاتهامات الامريكيه لها بتهديد
النظام العالمي وبنتهاك حقوق الانسان
وتعتبرها تدخل امريكيا في شؤونها الداخليه
وتعديا على سيادتها
لن توفر الولايات المتحده جهدا في استغلال
تهديد الصين في حل مشاكلها فحسب بل ستقول
العالم الى هويه خطيره
بينما يؤمن الجانبان انه لا تزال هناك
مصالح مشتركه بينهما وينفيان رغبتهما في
تحويل المنافسه الى صراع تبدو سياسات
البلدين تجاه بعضهما اقرب الى المواجهه
منها الى المنافسه ناصر عبد الحق الجزيره
بيجين
ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
لواء فايز على ماذا تقوم سياسه الردع
الموسع ضد الصين وكيف تجهز الصين ضدها
هذا يعود الى 2012 عندما عقد مؤتمر في
سنغافوره حضروا 30 دوله
ورامبانيت وزير الدفاع الامريكي في تلك
الفتره بناء على ما تقدم به الحضور تحدث
عن اعاده التوازن العسكري للقوات
الامريكيه ومنذ ذلك التاريخ بنشطه
الولايات المتحده في عقد اتفاقه اتفاقيات
الدفاع مشترك سواء كان ثنائيه او ثلاثيه
او رباعيه
وبدات تعيد بناء قوتها في تلك المنطقه حيث
يوجد لها الان بما في القواعد العسكريه في
جزرها هاواي الامريكيه يوجد اربعين قاعده
عسكريه يوجد الاسطول
السابع وهو الاسطول الرئيسي يوجد به ثلاث
حاملات طائرات يوجد به 50 غواصه منها 12
غواصه تواجد دائم يوجد بها سفن الابرار us
امريكا وغير ذلك ويوجد 330 الف يوجد ثلاثه
انواع من القواعد العسكريه يوجد منها
قواعد استراتيجيه معظمها في اليابان
واقوام هناك قواعد عملياتيه في سنغافور
وهناك قواعد او ما يطلق عليها الاماكن
المقدسه وهي القواعد الموجوده في الدول
الاخرى والتي تستطيع الوصول اليها
لماذا كل هذا
التموضع الامريكي والاستداره الاستراتيجيه
عندما كان الحديث يدور عن اخلاء الشرق
الاوسط من اجل التوجه الى بحر الصين
الجنوبي لماذا لان تفسير الوضع القائم غير
متفق عليه الوضع القائم يعني مياه بحريه
حره في المفهوم الامريكي في المفهوم
الصيني وبعد البدع في بناء ما يسمى الجزر
الاصطناعيه والجدار الرملي العظيم هي
تحاول ان تفرض لغه امر واقع بحيث تعتبر
منطقه اقتصاديه صينيه خالصه ماذا يترتب
على ذلك يتربع يترتب على ذلك عدم حريه
المرور علما ان من المضائق ويوجد ممر ملكه
ومضيق التايوان تمر منه 50% من التجاره
الدوليه ومخزونات النفط والغاز في بحر
الصين الجنوبي اذا دعيني اقول الصين بدات
تعزز وجودها من خلال الجزر الاصطناعيه
والجدار الرمل العظيم
ودفع قوات الى هذه الجزر وامريكا تعزز
وجودها ولكنه لا اقول عنه صراع بقدر ما هو
تنافس محموم حدود العليا باختصار نشاهد
هذه الثنائيه بين الطرفين الاقتراب من
التصادم التصعيد بينهما وفي نفس الوقت
التمسك بلغه الحوار والدبلوماسيه كيف يفهم
هذا الامر
يفهم الان امريكا تعتبر بناء على تصريحات
المسؤولين الامريكيين الصين هي التحدي
الرئيسي
وهذا منوط بثلاثه ابعاد البعد الاول النمو
الاقتصادي البعد الثاني التطوير التقني
والعسكري البعد الثالث التمدد الجغرافي من
خلال طريق ما يطلق عليه طريق الحرير
والوصول والوصول حتى الى عمق افريقيا والى
امريكا اللاتينيه ولكن بينما كانت تصنف
روسيا على انها دوله اقليميه عظمى نوويه
اذا امريكا تعتبر التحدي الرئيسي لها
الصين وعليها مواجهه هذا التحدي الرئيسي
شكرا جزيلا لك لواء فايزه دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفا من عمان
التجاذبات والسياسيه في بحر جنوب الصين
قديمه وتعد من اعقد الخلافات المائيه في
العالم التقرير التالي يرصد لنا ابرز نقاط
الخلاف في بحر جنوب الصين والى ماذا تستند
الاطراف في الدعاءاتها للسيطره على البحر
يعد بحر جنوب الصين اكثر الممرات المائيه
في العالم اثاره للخلافات والنزاعات
السياسيه بسبب تسارع عده دول للسيطره عليه
واهميته اللوجستيه والاقتصاديه
تكمن اهميه بحر جنوب الصين اللوجستيه في
انه ممر حيوي لنحو الثلث التجاره العالميه
حيث تمر البضائع من جنوب الصين وشرق اسيا
باتجاه غرب اسيا وافريقيا واوروبا عبر كل
من مضيق تايوان وملكه
كما يحتوي البحر على ثروات سمكيه كبيره
اضافه الى ما يقدر بنحو 11 مليار برميل من
النفط ومئه وتسعين تريليون قدم مكعبه من
الغاز الطبيعي غير المستخرج والذي تحتاجه
دول المنطقه بشده الاقتصاداتها
تتنازع على السيطره المباشره على البحر
سبع حكومات هي ماليزيا وبروني والفلبين
وفيتنام واندونيسيا والصين اضافه الى
تايوان
تحاول هذه الحكومات باستثناء الصين
وتايوان اللجوء الى تعريفات في اتفاقيه
الامم المتحده لقانون البحار لتحديد
مياهها الاقليميه والاقتصاديه في حين تلجا
الصين وتايوان الى ما تقولان انها حقوق
تاريخيه لهما في البحر فيما يعرف بخط
القطاعات التسعه
وتتنازعان فيما بينهما على هذا التعريف
كذلك ويسمح هذا الخط للصين بالسيطره على
نحو التسعين في المئه من البحر يزيد من
تعقيد هذا المشهد سيطره عدد من الدول على
جزر داخل البحر كجزر
ولكن ليس كل الجزر تسمح للدوله ببسط
سيطرتها على المياه حسب القانون الدولي
فالجزر التي يمكن السكن فيها هي جزر تعطي
للدوله حقا في المياه الاقليميه او
الاقتصاديه في حين لا تعطي الجزر التي
تغمر بالمياه وتنحسر عنها نتيجه المد
والجزر حق السيطره للدوله وهنا ياتي صراع
النفوذ في ظل غياب اتفاق دولي واضح على
السيطره تسعى الصين الى بناء قواعد عسكريه
على جزر وشعاب مرجانيه كانت مغموره تحت
الماء فيما بات يعرف بالجزر الصناعيه تسمع
هذه الجزر والقواعد العسكريه للصين
بالزياده نفوذها عمليا داخل البحر اما
الولايات المتحده فمهتمه ببقاء بحر جنوب
الصين مياه دوليه تسمح بحريه حركه الملاحه
كما تقول فتسير ما تسميها عمليات حريه
الملاحه وتمر المدمرات الامريكيه بشكل
متكرر ضمن بحر جنوب الصين ومنها مسارات
بالقرب من جزر ستراكي التي بنت الصين
قواعدها عليها فالولايات المتحده تعتبر
هذه العمليات حفاظا على الحقوق والحريات
الملاحيه في بحر جنوب الصين حسب القانون
الدولي في حين تنفي الصين الاتهامات
الامريكيه لها بانها تعرقل حريه الملاحه
او الطيران وتتهم الولايات المتحده بتعمد
اثاره التوتر في المنطقه
منتصف الليل مشاهدينا الكرام تقريبا
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه نتابع معكم في الساعه
الثانيه من حصادي هذه الليله والبدايه
بالعناوين
تصعيد ما بعد تفهمات العقبه جيش الاحتلال
يحاصر اريحا بعد مقتل مستوطن في اطلاق نار
ويفرض طوقا امنيا على حواره وقرى جنوبي
نابلس وينشر كتيبه اضافيه في الضفه لتامين
المستوطنات والخارجيه الامريكيه تدين عنف
المستوطنين العشوائي والواسع ضد المدنيين
الفلسطينيين
الازمه تتصاعد في تونس جبهه الخلاص
المعارضه تدعو للتظاهر للمطالبه بالافراج
عن المعتقلين السياسيين من جميع التيارات
مع احتدام المعارك في باخمه شرقيه
اوكرانيا
روسيا تقول ان المبادره الصينيه للسلام
يجب ان تراعي مصالح الاطراف كافه
يحذر الغرب تعرض روسيا للخطر سيعني ان
مصير العالم لن يتقرر في اوكرانيا وانما
خارج حدودها
[موسيقى]
من جديد مضيق تايوان في الواجهه بعد اعلان
وزاره دفاع تحليق طائره عسكريه امريكيه
فوق المضيق بيجين تندد وتعتبر الخطوه
تهديدا لامن واستقرار المضيق وسفير واشنطن
لديها يقول ان حفاظ بلاده على القوه
العسكريه في تايوان ومحيطها ياتي لضمان
رضع اي هجمات صينيه على الجزيره
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان ان مسلحين
داخل سياره اطلقوا النيران على سياره
اسرائيليه عند مفترق لطرق جنوب البحر
الميت في منطقه الاغوار ما ادى الى مقتل
اسرائيلي اضاف البيان انهم واصلوا التحرك
نحو اريحا واطلقوا النار واستهدفوا سياره
ثانيه بينما كانوا يغادرون المكان وقال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه اشتبك معهم اثناء
حرقهم لسياراتهم لكنهم فروا من المكان
بيان الجيش اضاف ان الجيش والشرطه يقومان
بعمليه تمشيط واسعه النطاق بحثا عنهم وقد
تم نشر الحواجز العسكريه وتشديد عمليات
التفتيش حول اريحا وقالت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه ان العمليه تاتي في اطار الرد
على جرائم الاحتلال ومستوطنيه
هذا واعلن جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تعزيز
قوته في منطقه نابلس الشماليه الضفه
الغربيه بكتيبه عسكريه رابعه منذ بدء
تعزيز قوته في المنطقه الليله الماضيه
ياتي قرار جيش الاحتلال عقب مشاورات
اجراها وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي مع قياده
الجيش خلال جوله تفقديه في موقع عمليه
حواره التي اسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنين اثنين
وقد حملت السلطه الفلسطينيه حكومه نتنياهو
مسؤوليه هجمات المستوطنين في حواره
اعرب المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه نيد برايس عن قلق الاداره
الامريكيه الشديد ازاء العنف الذي وقع في
بدايه الاسبوع في اسرائيل والضفه الغربيه
وقال ان الهجمات التي ادت الى مقتل
فلسطينيا واصابه اكثر من 300 اخرين بجروح
خطيره واحراق منازل وسيارات فلسطينيه هي
اعمال غير مقبوله على الاطلاق اضاف برايس
انه يتوقع من الحكومه الاسرائيليه ضمان
المسائله الكامله للمسؤولين عن الهجمات
على الفلسطينيين وتقديم تعويضات عن
المنازل والممتلكات المفقوده واكد ان
واشنطن تريد ان ترى الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين ينفذون الالتزامات التي
اقروها في بيان اجتماع العقبه في الاردن
واشار الى ان الاسرائيليين وافقوا على عدم
ترخيص اي او عدم ترخيص اي بؤره استيطانيه
جديده لمده سته اشهر على الاقل وتتوقع
واشنطن
منهم الوفاء بالتزاماتهم
معنى من واشنطن
في مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط سيد تشارلز
دان ما الذي سيترتب على هذا الموقف
الامريكي الذي عدد سلسله مطالب من اسرائيل
ان لم تنفذها
لم تنفذ اسرائيل
المطالب وما التزمت به في اجتماع العقبه
هذا يؤدي الى اجتماعات اضافيه في حقيقه
الامر اتفق الاطراف بالاجتماع او على
الاجتماع مجددا في شهر مارس اذا ما نظرنا
باتفاق وتفاصيل اتفاق العقبه اذا المحتوى
كان محدودا طبعا يلتزم الطرفان
بالحديث
وبخفض التصعيد ولكن بالنسبه الى التفاصيل
هي محدوده وما قالته الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اظهر انها ليست على استعدادا
لالزام الطرفين بالتصرف بطريقه او باخرى
يعني هل المسؤولون الامريكيون يعتقدون ان
المزيد من الاجتماعات ستحل الازمه ما ان
انتهى اجتماع العقبه كانت اسرائيل قد نقضت
كل ما ورد في البيان الختامي له ما الذي
سيحله المزيد من الاجتماعات
لا اعتقد ان المزيد من الاجتماعات سوف
تحسن الوضع في الميدان الا في حال كانت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الدقيقه
بالنسبه الى ما سوف تطلبهم من السلطه
الفلسطينيه ومن الحكومه الاسرائيليه يبدو
ان هذه هي المشكله ويجب على الطرفين ان
يتحكم بالموضوع اسرائيل يتعين عليها ان
تحقق فيما حصل في الضفه الغربيه ويتعين
على اسرائيل ان توقف المرتكبين وتحاكم
المرتكبين والقوات الامنيه الاسرائيليه
يجب ان تضع حدا لما يحصل عوضا عن
البقاء مكتوبه اذا هذه هي النقاط التي يجب
ان تضغط في شان الولايات وهذا هو السؤال
سيد تشارلز ان لم تفعل اسرائيل ذلك ويبدو
ان التوجه انها لن تفعل
ماذا سيحصل عندها
اعتقد ان اداره بايدن هي في موقف صعب
للغايه نحن نتحدث عن السنه انتخابيه مقبله
بالاضافه الى الجمهوريين الذين يسيطرون
على جزء من الكونجرس وبالتالي لا تود
الاداره ان تظهر بمظهر الجهه التي تضغط
على اسرائيل تفضل الاداره الامريكيه ان
تعمل او تتحدث عن اهميه تعزيز اتفاقيه
ابراهام او اتفاقات ابرهام وتعزيز الحوار
هذا لا يعني ان الوضع الفلسطيني سوف يتحسن
بالضروره الاحداث التي شاهدناها في الايام
الماضيه تشير الى هذا الاتجاه في الموقف
في واشنطن يبدو ان الاداره الامريكيه ليس
لديها اجابات واضحه يمكن ان تبدا
وتحاول ان تعمل على دبلوماسيه مكوكيه بين
القدس ورام الله وهذا يؤدي الى اظهار
المصلحه الامريكيه بتنفيذ امور عمليه ولكن
طبعا لا ارى ان الاداره سوف تلزم الطرفين
القيام بامور شكرا كبير الباحثين في مركز
دراسات الشرق الاوسط ضيفنا من واشنطن
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البوديري زارت بلده
حواره في نابلس بالضفه الغربيه ورصدت اثار
الاعتداءات وما خلفه احراق مستوطنين عددا
من المنازل
قبل قليل راينا موكب لوزير القومي
الاسرائيلي
يمر هنا من الشارع الرئيسي في بلده حواره
تحت حراسه الامنيه اسرائيليه مشدده بالطبع
المنطقه مغلقه بالكامل لا اي فلسطيني يسمح
له بالدخول او الخروج اذا كل مداخل حواره
تقريبا مغلقه هذه البلده التي توصل نابلس
بجنوب ووسط الضفه الغربيه نحن هنا امام
احد المنازل التي تم احراقها من قبل
المستوطنين ليله امس كما نرى المشهد يتحدث
عن نفسه حرق كامل للمنزل الدخان لا زلزال
يتصاعد من ما اكده لنا الاهالي انه في
داخل هذا البيت كان على الاقل هناك خمس
نساء وعدد من الاطفال اضطروا للهرب فور
رؤيه المستوطنين يدخلون الى عمق المنطقه
الحقيقه هنا وهو داخل احد الاصدقاء
القريبه من الشارع الرئيس الترولي الهرب
وصل عدد من الشبان وحاولوا التصدي
للمستوطنين الذين اكد الاهالي ان عددهم
كان يزيد عن 200 هذا واحد من اكثر من 30
منزلا تم حرقه من قبل المستوطنين الذين
دخلوا الى البلده من كافه الاجهاد تحت
حمايه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
معنا من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام لحركه المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ومن الناصره ايهاب جبارين
الباحث المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي مرحبا
بكما دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي باعتقادك ما
الرساله التي حملتها هذه الهجمات التي
نفذها المستوطنون في حواره بالامس بهذا
العنف
الرساله واضحه انهم مجرمون فاشيون لا
يريدوا اي وجود فلسطيني على هذه الارض
والرساله ايضا واضحه انهم لا يفهمون الا
لغه القوه
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه التقطت هذه الرساله
وبالتالي نحن نرى الان تصاعد في عمليات
المقاومه ضدها ضد هذا الاجرام الاسرائيلي
وضد المستوطنين المستعمرين الذين ارتكبوا
واحده من ابشع الجرائم بهجمه فاشيه وحشيه
على حواره
وعدد من المناطق الفلسطينيه الاخرى مثل
زعتره وبرين والعصير القبليه الذي نواجه
الان هجمه بربريه فاشيه واسرائيل تقول
بكل منها لا تفهم الى لغه القوه وهذا
الاستيطان لن يردع الا بمقاومته وفر
ض يا سيدي ايهاب جبارين لماذا ذهب الطرف
الاسرائيلي الى اجتماع العقبه وما ان
انتهى الاجتماع كان قد انقلب على نتائجه
يعني هل هذا بامر جديد نحن راينا ذلك في
الاسبوع الماضي مع قرارات مجلس الامن وما
قبل ذلك في عده تداعيات اخرى يعني اظن انه
من كلاسيكيات الردود الفعل الاسرائيليه
انها لا يعني تحترم ايه مواثيق وليس هذا
بالامر الجديد بتاتا ولكن على الرغم من كل
ذلك اظن ان الصوره المركبه في داخل
اسرائيل تحديدا في داخل هذه الحكومه هي
مرقبه من ثلاثه معايير اساسيه استراتيجيه
بنيامين نتنياهو ديولوجيه
وشعبويه بينج بير يعني هذه ثلاثه مركبات
هي التي تحرك الصوره وكلها باضداد يعني لا
تتحرك بصوره ممنهجه مع بعض بشراكه معينه
على العكس تماما هي تتحرك باضداد الى هدف
واحد بدون اي شك انه الهدف في نهايه
المطاف هو هدف واحد يعني بسطه السيطره
الاسرائيليه الاستيطانيه في داخل الضفه
الغربيه لكن ومع ذلك يجب القول ان كل منهم
نهجهوا بنهايه المطاف بين يمين نتنياهو
يعني لديه اسلوبه الدبلوماسي من جهه لا
يريد اثاره غضب الشركاء الامريكيين على
الاقل ليس في هذه المرحله من جهه اخرى
ومن ناحيه اخرى هو يريد يعني نوعا ما ضرب
بسوقهم السياسي الانتخابي في داخل اسرائيل
بالنسبه
ان صح القول يعني يمكن دمجهما مع بعض لكلا
منه ما يريد ان يؤجج ما كان وعد به ناخبيه
في الفتره الانتخابيه الان يكون لديه
سيطره معينه يعني كل منهم اخذ نوع من اخذ
وزاره في داخل وزاره الجيش الاسرائيلي بين
جبير يعني حتى غير اسم الوزاره لوزاره
الامن القومي او الامر الاول الذين فعلوا
يعني قاموا بتفعيله حتى في الميزانيات هو
تفعيل ميليشيات يمكن القول وتسميتها
بميليشيات خاصه بالمستوطنين اظن ان ما
نراه الان في داخل
حوارما رايناه في داخل حواره هو تاكيد ان
الارض ليست المشكله في هذا الوضع ما يغلق
منام
هو كيفيه تفريغ مناطق من سكانها
الاصلانيين مصطفى السلطه الفلسطينيه تقول
انها ذهبت الى اجتماع العقبه لوضع المطالب
الفلسطينيه على الطاوله في هذه المرحله
كيف يمكن تقييم هذا التصرف
تصرف خاطئ نحن قلنا راينا بكل وضوح لانه
نتيجه الاجتماع واضحه كالشمس قبل ان يجف
حبر الورق الذي كتب عليه الاعلان كان
المجرمون يجتاحون حواره
وماذا وعد الاسرائيليون حتى لم يعدوا حتى
القرار لم يكن وقف الاستيطان يعني هناك
عباره شائعه مضلله عندما يقال انه كانه
كان مكتوب في البيان وقت في الاستيطان ما
فيش حديث عن وقف الاستيطان الحديث عن وقف
اي خطط جديده ومع ذلك
بعد ساعات انهم لن يوقفوا شيء حتى التخطيط
الاستيطان لذلك هذا الاجتماع لم يثمر عن
شيء وانا برايي مجرد الحديث او الرغبه في
التفاوض مع الاسرائيليين من موقف ضعف هو
يعني خطا كبير علينا ان نغير ميزان القوى
قبل ان يجري الحديث عن المفاوضات وعليه
وعلى هذا النهج الذي فشل على مدار 32 عاما
ان ينتهي ويتوقف وفيما يتعلق بالقول
الامريكي انه يجب مسائله
اللذيذ انا اسال الموقف اين الموقف
الامريكي من حقيقه ان اسرائيل بعد مرور
اشهر على جريمه اغتيال شيرين ابو عاقل
التي كانت الجنسيه الامريكيه بالاضافه الى
الجنسيه الفلسطينيه لم تحاسب احد لماذا
تصمت الاداره الامريكيه على ذلك
اسرائيل كلام والولايات المتحده غير
مستعده للضغط على اسرائيل او فرض عقوبات
عليها ولكن انا برايي ان الاستراتيجيه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه الصحيحه هي التي تثبت
على ارض الواقع وهي استراتيجيه المقاومه
والكفاح والنضال وتوحيد الصرف الوطني على
الارض
والضغط شعبيا لفرض المقاطعات والعقوبه على
اسرائيل العقوبات والمقاطعه على اسرائيل
هذا هو الذي سيثمر تغيير ميزان القوى على
الارض وليس الركض وراء مفاوضات عقيمه لن
تجدي نفعا مع هؤلاء المسلمين
ماذا يعني في ضوء الاجندات المتعدده في
داخل هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه وتصعيد
الحاصل ما هو مستقبل هذه الحكومه
هذه الحبوب يعني احد اهم الامور التي لا
يريدها نتنياهو باي شكل من الاشكال هو
تاجيج الاوضاع في داخل
الضفه لانه لا يريد ان يتحول ما يجري في
الضفه الى هبه شعبيه
الاجهزه الامنيه
ونتنياهو على نهجهم حاولوا الاستفراد بؤر
في داخل الضفه
وعملوا جاهدين الا تكون هنالك سلسله من
الاستنفارات ما بين المدن يعني المختلفه
في داخل الضفه يعني عندما كانت تضييق على
جنين كان نوع من الاريحيه والبحبوحه ان صح
القول في مناطق اخرى يعني هذا من النوع
كان من السياسات الان يجب ان ندرك ان
بالاضافه الى يعني الجبهه الامنيه الغير
مستقره بالنسبه نتنياهو الجبهه
الدبلوماسيه وكذلك يعني يمكن القول ان
علاقاته حتى مع شركائه العالميين مثل
الولايات المتحده وغيرهم ليست مستقره
البته في هذه المرحله ان نتنياهو يواجه
كذلك توتر اقت غير مسبوق على اظن على
الاقل في العشرون عام الاخير اضف الى ذلك
الميدان يعني على شفير نوع من
العصيان المدني بكل ما يتعلق بالقضايا
وكنا قد ذكرنا المساله الامنيه واضيف الى
هذا كلياته سياسيا في داخل هذا الائتلاف
هنالك مساله عظم ثقه يعني لا احد يثق باي
احد اليوم كنا قد شاهدنا كيف عاقب بنجبير
ويهددها وعقبت نتنياهو في احد التصفيطات
في داخل الكنيست فبالتالي هنالك نوع من
البلبله يعني ما كان يقال ان هذه الحكومه
هي حكومه اليمين
الكامل المتكامل نسبه لمصوتي اليمين باتت
هي يعني نوع من حكومه البلبل المتجانسه
الغير متجانسه هذا يعني
المستوطن الذي قتل اليوم هو رقم 15
فبالتالي يعني هنالك نوع من التوتر اظن ان
مستقبل ما يعمل عليه نتنياهو في هذه
المرحله هو اضافت بيني جانس كلاعب تعزيز
بديلا
عنهدئ من الوتيره التصعيدات في هذه
الجبهات المختلفه شكرا لك ايهاب جبانين
البحث المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي من
الناصره وشكرا للدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام لحركه المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ضيفنا من رام الله
المواجهات بين المستوطنين والفلسطينيين في
الضفه الغربيه لا تكاد تغادر اربعه محاور
رئيسيه وتحديدا المناطق المحيطه
بالمستوطنات والبؤر الاستيطانيه الكبرى
[تصفيق]
حيثما يستشري الاستيطان تحتدم المواجهه في
الضفه الغربيه بين الفلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال والمستوطنين بنظره قريبه الى
جغرافيا الضفه يمكن تحديد بؤر الاشتباك
الاكثر اشتعالا جنوب نابلس حيث بلده حواره
وبورين عشرون مستوطنه وثلاثون بؤره
استيطانيه تلتهم محافظه نابلس تحديدا جنوب
المحافظه يضم هذا السياج مستوطنات براخا
ويتسار ورحليم ومجدلي وغيرها 40 الف
مستوطن تؤويهم هذه المستوطنات جلهم من
اليهود المتطرفين وجماعات تدفيع الثمن
شمال رام الله بؤره اشتباكات اخرى بين
الفلسطينيين والمستوطنين وقوات الاحتلال
حيث مستوطنه الشيلو المقامه على اراضي
بلدتي ترموسعيه والمغير والشيلو من
المستوطنات الدينيه حيث يقطنها مستوطنون
ينتمون الى اليمين المتطرف ما بين بيت لحم
والخليل يقع مفترق غوش اتسيون من هناك يمر
الاسرائيليون والفلسطينيون باستمرار لعده
اعوام وصف هذا المكان حيث مستوطنه
احد اخطر الاماكن في الضفه الغربيه وفي
قلب مدن الضفه تستشري بؤر استيطانيه كما
في قلب الخليل حيث كريات اربع ومستوطنات
جبل الخليل في ذاكره الفلسطينيه كان
للخليل ارث دام من جرائم المستوطنين
فكريات اربع توصف بانها وكر للحركه
العنصريه والمتطرفه كاخ التي اسسهانا
ومنها انطلق بروهكولدشتاين عام
1994 لينفذ مذبحه الحرم الابراهيمي وفي
كريات اربع يقيم وزير الامن القومي اتمر
بنج فير صاحب مشروع قانون اعدام كل
فلسطيني ينفذ هجوما ضد اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
الى تونس حيث قال رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني
احمد نجيب الشابي ان الحمله القمعيه
الحاليه ضد المعارضين ليست سوى تجل من
تجليات تخبط السلطه وفي مؤتمر صحفي اعلن
ان الجبهه ستنظم مظاهره في العاصمه الاحد
القادم للمطالبه باطلاق سراح جميع
المعتقلين
الشيء هذا احنا كنا متوقعين قبل
الانتخابات
واعلنا عنه منذ شهر او جوان الماضي لان
هذا الحكم الفردي المطلق ما ينجم يبسط
نفوذه الا باسكات صوت المعارضين وصوت كل
نفس حر في هذا البلد وقلنا بان القيادات
الحركه السياسيه
والمدنيه الاجتماعيه النقابيه مستهدفه
ايضا
ينضم الينا من تونس سمير ديلو عضو اللجنه
التنفيذيه الخلاص الوطني وعضو هيئه الدفاع
عن المعتقلين المتهمين بالتامل على امن
الدوله ومن تونس ايضا احمد الهمامي
المتحدث باسم تحالف احرار مرحبا بكما سيد
احمد الهمامي اذن وفق السيد الشابي الامور
مدبره وهذا تجلى لحكم الفرد هذا هذا
الاستهداف المباشر لجميع المعارضين
شكرا
سمير ديلو نعم هو يقول ما يريد
وتعودنا بالتخبط من
الخلاص وتعودنا من التباكي السياسي
والارتماء والدوره لعبه الضحيه دور الضحيه
ولكن هذا مردود عليه فاليوم في تونس
القضاء يقوم بدوره ودور تاريخي لانه نحن
في الان في حرب تحرير وطني كما قال الرئيس
قيس سعيد من اجل تحديد البلاد لمن افسدوا
في العشرينات التي تمت السيد احمد من جانب
المعارضه بان القضاء الذي تقولون انه يقوم
بدوره جرد من كل امكانيه ان يكون موضوعيا
ومجردا واصبح بتصرف الرئيس
لو كان هذا الكلام مردود عنه لانه هكذا
نتهم القضاء التونسي بانه غير محاربهم غير
محاكي ولكن
المسلسل في جانبك وهو يمارس يوميا في
المحاماه وتقريبا في وسط القضايا يعني
يعرف الاجراءات التي تمت الايقافات التي
تمت هي ذات اجراءات قانونيه وفي الاجل
القانونيه وهم مضمون ومكفور لهم كمحامين
بالدفاع عن موكليهم ونحن نريد المحاسبه
مطلب شعبي ولا نريد التشفي يعني من اخطا
في العشريه السوداء فهو يحاسب ولمن ولم
يقتل فسوف يكون في حاله يعني يبرا من قبل
القضاء فقط ملاحظه اريد ان اسوقها يعني
بالطبعا الناس تقول ان هناك ايقافات
للمعارضين الرئيس قيس سعيد لا نحن
الايقافات التي تمت هي لبعض من كانوا
مسؤولين في الدوله من وزراء من السياسيين
مارس السياسه مارسوا عشريه سوداء لانه
ممكن الذين يحكمون اذن نحن كشعب التونسي
عندما نطالب
للرئيس السعيد على كل دعنا نسال سيد سمير
ديلو سيد سمير اذا الامور متروكه للقضاء
لماذا لا تثقون بهذه العمليه
عدم الثقه ليس موجه القضاء وانما هو موجه
لمن
يريد لوظيفك بالمناسبه يطلب مني اداء
شهاده زور بالتصريح بان الاجراءات قد تم
احترامها وفي الواقع لم يتم احترام اي
اجراء تمت متهمات للمنازل بدون اذن قضائي
الاذن القضائيه اعطيت من بعد تصحيح
الاجراءات تم ترويع العائلات تمت عمليه
تفتيش وحجز خارج الاطر القانونيه اما
مضمون الملفات فحدث ولا حرف ولا حرج
زميلنا الاستاذ المحامي نزل العكرمي اليوم
احيل في قضيه متهم فيها بالتامل لوحده هذه
اول مره في تاريخ القضاء في العالم وليس
في تونس واحد وحدها هناك مؤامره لاسقاط
نظام الحكم متهم فيها شخص وحيد فريد
بالنسبه لبقيه الموقوفين هم تاج على
رؤوسنا الاستاذه شيماء عيسى الاستاذ جوهر
بن مالك رئيس الحزب الجمهوري الاستاذ عصام
شابي الاستاذ عبد الحميد الجلاسي الاستاذ
رضا بالحاج هؤلاء مناض
كل ذنبهم ان امسحوا الى توحيد اطراف
المعارضه ولكن هذه السلطه لا تقبل بالراي
المخالف اما الحديث عن القضاء فكل العالم
يعلم ان هذا القضاء قد تم تجريده من كل
صلاحيته قد تم استهدافه السلطه تعتبره
وظيفه ودور الموظف هو ان يطبق التعليمات
رد عليك سيد احمد الهمامي ولكن سيد احمد
انت تقول ان ما يجري هو لمحاسبه كل من
شارك في العشريه السوداء ماذا نفهم من هذا
الكلام الى اين ستصل هذه الاجراءات
شكرا لك مره اخرى واريد ان اسال السيد
سمير فقط سؤال من الذي شرد القضاء من
مهامه او من صفاته يا ريت ان يدلنا ويدل
الشعب التونسي من الشخص او الاشخاص وما
اثبتته على هذا على ما يقوله اعود لك نحن
وطلبنا بالمحاسبه لماذا المحاسبه الذي
اخطا واوصل البلاد في عشريه سنوات كانت
عشريه سوداء فعلا اقتصاديا واجتماعيا
السيد سيد احمد الى اين تريد هذه الى اين
يراد لهذا المسار ان يصل
الى محاسبه كل من اجرم في بتونسيه وبنايه
وبناء الدوله الجديده وفي الشهر القادم
سيرتكز البرلمان الجديد البرلمان وتعود
تونس الى دواليب الدوله العاديه والخروج
من الحاله الاستثنائيه وتركيز المؤسسات
الدستوريه واهمها المحكمه الدستوريه واذا
هناك لديهم يستطيعون التوجه نحو تلك
اللحظه الدستوريه ونقض او معارضه الرئيس
قيس سعيد بالطرق القلب ويا ريت يجيبني على
من هو شخص او الاشخاص
الذي قضاء
الان نسمعك تفضل جاوب على السؤال لو سمحت
الذي جرد هو رئيس الجمهوريه قيس سعيد الذي
حل المجلس الاعلى للقضاء والذي اعفى 57
قاضيا والذي رفض تطبيق حكم المحكمه
الاداريه التي عادت 49 قاضيا الى مهامهم
هو الذي حرم على القضاه ان يحكموا بالعدل
واعتبر ان من يبرئ هؤلاء فهو شريك لهم هو
الذي ضرب قرينه البراءه باعتبار ان هؤلاء
مجرمون وارهابيون وانهم بمثابه الخلايا
السرطانيه التي يجب بمواجهتها بالكيمياوي
وبعضهم ما زال لم يوجه له اي اتهام بعد
اذا هذا السؤال من المفروض ان سيد سمير
الان جبهه الخلاص المعارضه تدعو لتظاهرات
حتى تحرير كل الموقوفين هل يتناسب هذا
الاجراء باعتقادك مع حجم الفعل
نحن
العملونيه تم تشكيل هيئه الدفاع ستعمل على
تحرير هؤلاء بكل ما هو متاح لها وفي
المقابل سنواصل العمل الميداني
المدني السلمي للضغط من اجل تحرير هؤلاء
المسجونين ظلما هؤلاء ليسوا ارابيين لم
يمارسوا عنف في حياتهم لم يدعو الى عمق
وهم مسجونون ظلما وعدوانا وقهرا ويكفي
الاطلاع الملفات للاسف الشديد ليس بامكاني
ان اطلعكم على مضمون الملفات المحميه
بسريه التحقيق ولكن كل من اطلع عليها يعرف
جيدا ان هذه السلطه قد اتخذت قرارا باسكات
والجام اصوات معارلها وهي الان بسبب
تنفيذه عبر تطوير القلق شكرا لك سمير ديل
عضو اللجنه التنفيذيه لجبهه الخلاص الوطني
وعضو هيئه الدفاع عن المعتقلين المتهمين
بالتامل على امن الدوله وشكرا للسيد احمد
الهمامي المتحدث باسم تحالف احرار ضيفان
من تونس
[موسيقى]
قال زعيم دنيا الموالي لروسيا ان الظروف
في جبهه بخموت مواتيه لتطويق من سماه
العدو وتضييق الحصار عليه اما مستشار فقال
ان ميليشيا فاجنر تخوض معارك في مركز
مدينه بخموت وان جميع الطرق المؤديه اليها
اصبحت تحت السيطره الناريه للقوات الروسيه
قال المتحدث باسم الكريم بشان خطه الصين
لتسويه النزاع في اوكرانيا ان بلاده متهمه
بالمقترح الصيني لكن الظروف اللازمه لحل
سلمي غير مهيئه في الوقت الراهن
[موسيقى]
في حضور صيني امريكي اخر نقلت وكاله
رويترز عن وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه قولها
ان طائره عسكريه امريكيه حلقت فوق مضيق
تايوان وقالت الوكاله ان الطائره
الامريكيه وهي من طراز بي ثمانيه
من الشمال الى الجنوب دون اعطاء مزيد من
التفاصيل
الجيش الصيني قال انه راقب الطائره
الامريكيه عن كسب وهي تحلق فوق المضيق
اضاف ان الامر يهدد الامن والاستقرار في
المضيق مشددت المؤسسه العسكريه الصينيه
على رفضها هذا العمل الامريكي
التنافس الامريكي الصيني يعكس صراعا حول
نفوذ والزعامه العالميين حيث تصفه الاوساط
السياسيه الامريكيه باكبر تحد جيوس
استراتيجي للولايات المتحده في القرن 21
الجزيره وفي سلسله تقارير خاصه بالملف
التوتر في شرق اسيا تسلط الضوء في اول
تقاريرها على اسباب التوتر بين اكبر قوتين
في العالم
رغم الود الظاهري خلال اخر لقاء بين
الرئيسين الامريكي والصيني الا ان التنافس
الدولي الذي يزداد حده بين اكبر قوتين
دوليتين يجعل العالم يقف برمته على اعتاب
حرب بارده في نسختها الثانيه
بحسب تقييمات البانتاجون فان الجيش الصيني
يعمل على تنويع منصات الصواريخ النوويه
لمواكبه توسع ترسانته كما انه اجرى
اختبارات لصواريخ البالستيه عام 2021 كانت
اكثر من بقيه دول العالم مجتمعه ويطور
صواريخ تفوق سرعه الصوت اما في مجال
الفضاء فتشتبه واشنطن النبييجين تعمل على
تطوير اقمار اصطناعيه للمراقبه وجمع
المعلومات وتسعى في الوقت نفسه لانشاء
قواعد عسكريه لها في انحاء العالم ينظر
ذلك بصراع هيمنه على مسارات تعتبرها
الولايات المتحده شريانا حيويا للملاحه
والتجاره الدوليه يكثر الحديث هنا عن
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادي
اتتهم الصين بانشاء مناطق خالصه لها في
بحر جنوب الصين بانشاءها جزرا صناعيه رغم
رفض جيرانها لما تصفه بمزاعم السياده
الصينيه وهي منطقه تلعب دورا حيويا في
تدفق النفط والتجاره لحلفاء واشنطن في شرق
اسيا كاليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وتايوان
الاقتصاد ورغم كون الصين ثالثه اكبر شريك
للولايات المتحده فان اتهامات واشنطن
لبيجين تواصلت بشان ممارسات اقتصاديه قالت
انها تنتهك قواعد منظمه التجاره العالميه
كنقل التكنولوجيا وسرقه الملكيه الفكريه
والاسرار التجاريه مخاوف واشنطن زادت بعد
اطلاق بيجين مبادره الحزام والطريق عام
2013 حيث تتوجس من ان هذه المبادره التي
وقعتها 146 دوله حتى الان ستعزز توسع
الصين العسكري وسطوتها الاقتصاديه في
العالم
ولا يقل التنافس في مجال التكنولوجيا في
اهميته عن باقي ابعاد هذا الصراع اذ اتخذت
الولايات المتحده اجراءات حظر على شركات
الرقائق الالكترونيه لبيع الشرائح
المتقدمه للصين والتي قد تستخدم في المجال
العسكري لاسيما التجسس
هنا ايضا تبقى تايوان ضمن اهم الخطوط
الحمراء التي تسعى الصين لمنع الولايات
المتحده من تجاوزها ولذا تسعى بشكل حثيث
لامتلاك قوه عسكريه نوعيه
تؤمن لها تفوقا في البحار من شرق الصين
حتى جنوبها هذا السعي تجلى واضحا في
مناورات الصين البحريه وطلعتها الجويه شبه
اليوميه بالقرب من تايوان بل تجاوز ذلك
لتجري بيجين تدريبات عسكريه في مناطق غرب
المحيط الهادئ وتقترب حامله طائراتها
لعونين من جزيره غوام اكبر قاعده عسكريه
امريكيه في المحيط
امام التغيرات الحاده بالوضع الدولي وخاصه
في وجه تصرفات الابتزاز والاحتواء والحصار
والضغط الشديد من الخارج
تمسكنا بمصالح الدوله
مصالح تمثلت في خطط اقتصاديه وصناعيه
طموحه وضعت الصين لتحقيقها سقفا زمنيا
محددا
في عام 2015
اعلنت الصين عن خطه صنع في الصين
لتحقيق التفوق في مجال الصناعات عاليه
التقنيه وبعدها بعامين اعلنت عن خطتها
لتحقيق الرياده في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي
بحلول عام 2030
لطالما وصفت الصين منع الولايات المتحده
الرقائق الالكترونيه
واشباه الموصلات عن كبريات شركاتها
التكنولوجيه بالقمع والاحتواء واعتبرته
وقوفا في طريق تطورها التقني الذي استثمرت
فيه مليارات الدولارات
تنفي الصين لاتهامات الامريكيه لها بتهديد
النظام العالمي وبنتهاك حقوق الانسان
وتعتبرها تدخل امريكيا في شؤونها الداخليه
وتعديا على سيادتها
لن توفر الولايات المتحده جهدا في
استغلالك تهديد الصين في حل مشاكلها فحسب
بل ستقول العالم الى هويه خطيره
بينما يؤمن الجانبان انه لا تزال هناك
مصالح مشتركه بينهما وينفيان رغبتهما في
تحويل المنافسه الى صراع تبدو سياسات
البلدين تجاه بعضهما اقرب الى المواجهه
منها الى المنافسه ناصر عبد الحق الجزيره
بيجين
التجاذبات السياسيه في بحر جنوب الصين
قديمه وتعد من اعقد الخلافات المائيه في
العالم التقرير التالي يرصد لنا ابرز نقاط
الخلاف في بحر جنوب الصين والى ماذا تستند
الاطراف في الدعاءاتها للسيطره على البحر
يعد بحر جنوب الصين اكثر الممرات المائيه
في العالم اثاره للخلافات والنزاعات
السياسيه بسبب تصارع عده دول للسيطره عليه
واهميته اللوجستيه والاقتصاديه
تكمن اهميه بحر جنوب الصين اللوجستيه في
انه ممر حيوي لنحو الثلث التجاره العالميه
حيث تمر البضائع من جنوب الصين وشرق اسيا
باتجاه غرب اسيا وافريقيا واوروبا عبر كل
من مضيق تايوان وملكه
كما يحتوي البحر على ثروات سمكيه كبيره
اضافه الى ما يقدر بنحو 11 مليار برميل من
النفط ومئه وتسعين تريليون قدم مكعبه من
الغاز الطبيعي غير المستخرج والذي تحتاجه
دول المنطقه بشده الاقتصاداتها
تتنازع على السيطره المباشره على البحر
سبع حكومات هي ماليزيا وبروني والفلبين
وفيتنام واندونيسيا والصين اضافه الى
تايوان
تحاول هذه الحكومات باستثناء الصين
وتايوان اللجوء الى تعريفات في اتفاقيه
الامم المتحده لقانون البحار لتحديد
مياهها الاقليميه والاقتصاديه في حين تلجا
الصين وتايوان الى ما تقولان انها حقوق
تاريخيه لهما في البحر فيما يعرف بخط
القطاعات التسعه
وتتنازعان فيما بينهما على هذا التعريف
كذلك
ويسمحوا هذا الخط للصين بالسيطره على نحو
التسعين في المئه من البحر يزيد من تعقيد
هذا المشهد سيطره عدد من الدول على جزر
داخل البحر كجزر
ولكن ليس كل الجزر تسمح للدوله ببسط
سيطرتها على المياه حسب القانون الدولي
فالجزر التي يمكن السكن فيها هي جزر تعطي
للدوله حقا في المياه الاقليميه او
الاقتصاديه في حين لا تعطي الجزر التي
تغمر بالمياه وتنحسر عنها نتيجه المد
والجزر حق السيطره للدوله وهنا ياتي صراع
النفوذ في ظل غياب اتفاق دولي واضح على
السيطره تسعى الصين الى بناء قواعد عسكريه
على جزر وشعاب مرجانيه كانت مغموره تحت
الماء فيما بات يعرف بالجزر الصناعيه تسمح
هذه الجزر والقواعد العسكريه للصين
بالزياده نفوذها عمليا داخل البحر اما
الولايات المتحده فمهتمه ببقاء بحر جنوب
الصين مياه دوليه تسمح بحريه حركه الملاحه
كما تقول فتسير ما تسميها عمليات حريه
الملاحه وتمر المدمرات الامريكيه بشكل
متكرر ضمن بحر جنوب الصين ومنها مسارات
بالقرب من جزر ستراكي التي بنت الصين
قواعدها عليها فالولايات المتحده تعتبر
هذه العمليات حفاظا على الحقوق والحريات
الملاحيه في بحر جنوب الصين حسب القانون
الدولي في حين تنفي الصين الاتهامات
الامريكيه لها بانها تعرقل حريه الملاحه
او الطيران وتتهم الولايات المتحده بتعمد
اثاره التوتر في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اظلوا في الصين حيث شجبت خارجيتها خلاصات
طرحتها وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه تفيد بان
كوفيد 19 تسرب اسراح حادث عرضيا في مختبر
صيني واعتبرت الخارجيه الصينيه الاتهامات
الجديده تشويها للبلاد وكانت صحف امريكيه
قد تحدثت عن توصل وزاره الطاقه لاستنتاج
بتسرب الفيروس وذلك اعتمادا على تقرير
استخباراتي سري لم يكشف مصدره ويسود
الاختلاف مواقف وكالات استخبارات امريكيه
بشان منشا كوفيد بعد مرور ثلاث سنوات على
ظهوره الاول في وهران الصينيه
كورونا عود على بدء لا يتعلق الامر هذه
المره بتفش جديد للفيروس وانما باستدعاء
اسئله البدايات عن المنشا والملابسات وفق
صحيفه
فان وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه خلصت الى
احتمال ان يكون كوفيد 19 نتاج التسرب عربي
من معهد علم الفيروسات الصيني في ووهان
وقد جاء الاستنتاج استنادا الى تقرير
استخباراتي سري قدم اخيرا الى البيت
الابيض واعضاء في الكونغرس لم يكشف عن
مصدر التقرير لكن صحيفتين اكدتا ان وزاره
الطاقه اصدرت حكمها بثقه منخفضه ورجحتها
ضمنا ان تكون الوزاره قد اعتمدت في
استنتاجها على شبكه المختبرات التي تشرف
عليها بما فيها تلك التي تجري ابحاثا
بيولوجيه متقدمه وسرعان ما ردت الخارجيه
الصينيه على الاتهام ات الجديده
على الاطراف المعنيه التوقف عن اثاره
الادعاءات بشان التسريبات المختبريه والكف
عن تشويه سمعه الصين وتسييس الابحاث
المتعلقه بمنشا الفيروس
الاستنتاجات العلميه الموثوقه التي توصل
اليها خبراء مشتركون من الصين ومنظمه
الصحه العالميه لم تعثر على اي دليل يؤكد
احتمالات تسرب الفيروس
تعليقا على هذا الجدل الامريكي الصيني
قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه انها ستواصل
مراجعه جميع الادله العلميه المتاحه التي
يمكن ان تساعد في كشف حقائق الفيروس
وبينما دعت المنظمه الصين والمجتمع العلمي
لاجراء الدراسات اللازمه اعتبرت ان جميع
الفرضيات تبقى قائمه
الاستنتاج الجديد يتقاطع مع موقف مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكي اف بي اي
القائل ايضا بتسرب الفيروس من مختبر صيني
لكن التقرير يتباين مع استنتاجات اربع
وكالات استخباراتيه امريكيه اخرى رجحت
بثقه منخفضه ايضا ان يكون منشا الفيروس
طبيعيا وامام هذه الاحكام المتباينه في
مجتمع الاستخبارات اكد جيكس سوليفان
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي اللا وجود
لاجابه نهائيه حتى الان عن اصل كورونا وان
اداره بايدن ستبلغ الكونغرس والجمهور حاله
توفر تلك المعلومات
وكما الحال في كل عام من المرتقب ان يطلع
قاده مجتمع الاستخبارات في الولايات
المتحده الكونغرس في مارس المقبل بما
لديهم من معلومات سريه بما في ذلك تلك
المتعلقه بجائحه كوفيد التي ظهرت قبل
ثلاثه اعوام واودت بحياتي نحو سبعه ملايين
انسان
[موسيقى]
نناقش في فقره المتابعه بدء روسيا ضخ
النفط الكازاخستاني الى المانيا التي
توقفت عن استيراد الخام الروسي وذلك عبر
احدى اكبر شبكات انابيب النفط الخام في
العالم خط انابيب دروغبا النفطي الذي دخل
مرحله التشغيل عام
1964 ينقل النفط الخام على امتداد
5500 كم من الجزء الشرقي من روسيا الى
اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا وبولندا والمجر
وسلوفاكيا وجمهوريه التشيك والمانيا تبلغ
قدره الخط الذي تشغله شركه روز ديفيد
النفطيه في روسيا نحو مليون و400 الف
برميل يوميا وتبدا الشبكه من مدينه
في روسيا حيث تلتقي الانابيب التي تحمل
النفط الخام من سيبيريا والاورال وبحر
قزوين ثم يتجه بعدها الخط الى مدير في
روسيا حيث يتوزع على فرعين شمالي وجنوبي
يمر الشمالي عبر بيلاروسيا الى بولندا
والمانيا في حين يمر الفرع الجنوبي عبر
اوكرانيا ليصل الى سلوفاكيا وتشيك
وهونغاريا تاتي صادرات كازاخستان النفطيه
في الوقت الذي تخطط فيه اوروبا لتقليل
اعتمادها على امدادات النفط الروسي منذ
بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
استثنى الاتحاد الاوروبي والدات الخامه
الروسي عبر الخطوط الانابيب من العقوبات
لمساعده الدول التي تملك خيارات محدوده
للشحنات البديله لكن المانيا وعدت بوقف كل
المشتريات النفطيه من روسيا خلال العام
الجاري والتحول جزئيا للاعتماد على
امدادات كازاخستان من الخام وتخطط شركه
النفط الكازاخستانيه
الف طن من النفط الى المانيا في الربع
الاول من العام الحالي
وكنت قد اجريت قبل الحصاد لقاء مع وزيره
المناخ البولنديه ان موسكوبا والتي تتضمن
مهامها الوزاريه ملف الطاقه وسالتها في
البدايه عن حرب الطاقه الدائره بين روسيا
واوروبا وهل هناك من كسب ومن خسر
ان بعض الدول مثل بولندا كانت مستعده
للاستقلاليه التامه عن روسيا منذ ان بدانا
نبني مسارا نحو الاستقلاليه منذ سنوات
الكثير من الاموال والكثير من الوقت لكي
نستقل في مجال الطاقه الغاز النفط وحتى
الفحم ولكن الكثير من الدول كانت تؤمن بان
هذا العلاقه مع روسيا تعطيها دعما في
المجال التجاري مجال الاعمال وفي مجال
الارباح ونحن
في المقابل كنا نعرف انها مساله سيطره
وهيمنه لهذا اردنا ان نستقل عن روسيا
ونجحنا في ذلك السنه الماضيه بغض النظر عن
الحرب خططنا منذ سنوات خططنا بالمنى
التحتيه والتعاقد والعقود وكنا مستعدين
للاستقلاليه عن روسيا اذا ما اثر القرار
الروسي الذي اتخذ قبل يومين بوقف تص النفط
الى بولندا
ان 19
ويل عام 2015
في المئه من النصف الروسي ومن ثم سنه تلو
الاخرى قمنا بتخفيض اعتماد على روسيا
وكذلك بفضل الالتزامات في مجال البنى
التحتيه او الاستثمارات في البنى التحتيه
الان اكتسبنا الاستقلاليه التامه عن
النفطه الروسيه ومصافين مساعده لتصفيات
كافه انواع النفط ولدينا عقوق طويلات
الاجل مع عديد من الدول بما فيها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبعض الدول الغربيه وبعد
الدول الافريقيه وبالتالي نحن مستقلون
استقلاليتان عن روسيا منذ ايام قليله
قررت روسيا الاتحاديه ان تتوقف عن امدادنا
ولكننا كنا نتوقع هذه الخطوه كان لدينا
عقد واحد من المس تحيل ان يتم انتهاكه
ولكن الان راينا ان روسيا اوقفت امداداتها
من حيث امن الطاقه نحن لسنا قلقين لاننا
خططنا منذ سنوات ما البديل الذي تؤمنونه
عن النفط الروسي الذي توقف
لدينا عدد من البدائل
لقد جربناها السنه الماضيه وهذه السنه كما
قلت لدينا عقود طويله الاجل مع ارامكو من
السعوديه
ومع دول غربيه اوروبيه والولايات المتحده
ونحن مستعدون
لاننا لسنا وحدين نحن ايضا ندعم دول كثيره
مثل ليتوانيا وتشيكيا طيب على صعيد اوروبا
ككل هل يمكن القول ان الخطوات التي اتخذت
من اجل وقف الاعتماد على الطاقه الروسيه
سهله
وناجعه ويمكن اتخاذها
هناك بعض الخطوات التي يمكن لي الدول
الاوروبيه ان تتخذها نحن بحاجه الى عقوبات
عقوبات كامله فيما يتعلق بالغاز وايضا
عقوبات فيما يتعلق بالنفط
ونتوقع عقوبات في مجال النووي هناك الكثير
من الدول الاوروبيه التي تعتمد على الطاقه
النوويه والوقود النووي وحان الوقت لكي
نقول كفى بالنسبه الى الاعتماد على روسيا
ايا كان هذا الاعتماد واعتقد ان الطاقه
النوويه هي الخطوه التاليه التي ستتخذ
الدول الاوروبيه خطوات بشانها لكن كان
الامر مرهونا بتقييم الوضع خلال فصل
الشتاء في اوروبا كيف يمكن تقييم الاوضاع
خلال فصل الشتاء المنصرم وهل انتهت الازمه
فيما يتعلق بالاعتماد على الطاقه الروسيه
هناك بعض الدول التي لديها بعض الاعتماد
على الغاز الروسي والكثير من الدول
الاوروبيه تنتج الطاقه من الغاز ما الذي
تحتاج هذه الدول الى القيام به عليها ان
تفعل ما فعلته بولندا منذ سنوات اي ان
تقوم بتشييد البنى التحتيه وان تتصل بكافه
الدول الاوروبيه ان يكون هناك شبكه
ستتوقع عقودا طويله
وعلينا ان نستخدم الموارد القابله للتجدد
التي يمكنها ان تستبدل الوقود الاحفوري
وغيره شكرا لك ان موسكو وزيره المناخ
البولنديه حدثتنا من ستوكهولم
مرت ثلاثه اسابيع على زلزال العنيف الذي
ضرب جنوبيه تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا لكن
الكثير من المشاهد والصور ستبقى في
الذاكره ربما لسنوات من بينها سوره مسعود
هندشر الذي يرتدي ستره برتقاليه ساكنا وسط
الاضطرابات غير مبال بالمطر والبرد وممسكا
بيد ابنته المتوفاه تحت الانقاض هي صوره
اصبحت رمزا لكارثه اودت بعشرات الالاف
وتصدرت الصفحات الاولى للعديد من الصحف في
العالم
وتشاركها الملايين عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي يروي هنتشر قصه هذه اللحظه
المؤلمه قائلا لم استطع ترك يدها كانت
ابنتي نائمه مثل الملاك في سريرها ويضيف
امسكت بيدها ولامست شعرها وقبلت خديها
ومن بين اشكال التضامن الانساني تزين لوحه
رسمها فنان تظهر ارمك كملاكن بجوار والدها
في الصالون في منزل العائله كل المواساه
لمن فقدوا الاحبه في هذه الكارثه شكرا لكم
على حسن متابعتي حصاد هذه الليله موجز
رياضي مع عمار نامق ثم نواصل من بعده
التغطيه الاخباريه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]